-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers
and this is "Late Night."
Before we get to the news,
we are taping this before we
have heard what the verdict is
in the Chauvin murder trial.
We just heard that a verdict
will be announced today,
but we are taping
this beforehand.
So if it seems conspicuous
in its absence,
that is the reason why.
I'm sure we'll have plenty
to say about it tomorrow.
However, if you're looking for
multiple jokes
about how today is 4/20,
allow us to be your sanctuary.
[ Laughter ]
Let's get to the news.
President Biden tweeted
yesterday that everyone
16 and older can now receive the
coronavirus vaccine and added,
"Go get 'em, folks."
Said teens, "Sure thing.
Just one question.
Um, what does 'folks' mean?"
President Biden released
a short video yesterday
encouraging Americans
to get the coronavirus vaccine
It wasn't supposed to be short
He just accidentally hit send.
-For months
I've been telling Ameri--
-"Son of a gun.
Jill!"
According to reports,
White House officials
are currently working on
a large spending plan
centered on child care
and paid family leave.
Not to be confused with
the last administration,
which was just a paid family
Georgia representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene announced
over the weekend that she plan
to introduce legislation
that would expel
Democratic Representative
Maxine Waters from Congress.
When asked if the move was
in response to Waters' comment
about protesters, Greene said,
"What comments?"
In a new interview,
former Republican Representative
Denver Riggleman said
that Representative
Marjorie Taylor Greene's
proposed America First caucu
is "racism in a jar."
So, mayonnaise?
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
announced yesterday he's suing
voting machine manufacture
Dominion for $1.6 billion.
Though he's just jealous
because their voting machine
are more comfortable to sleep on
than his pillows.
According to polls, American
are more interested in
trying edibles than any othe
type of cannabis product.
Wow. America's the only countr
that starts with the munchies.
Today was Lima Bean Respect Day.
In that case,
you taste like ass, good sir
[ Laughter ]
To celebrate 4/20, the
unofficial marijuana holiday
a New York City
cannabis activist hosted
a Joints for Jabs event toda
and gave anyone who would
receive the coronavirus vaccin
free marijuana, which explains
why so many New Yorkers
just got their third dose
of Pfizer.
[ Laughter ]
That was a very,
very good photo.